you
the mission is to make autonomous ships
a a commercial reality when we
originally set out to do that we thought
that it would happen a bit later at the
2025 ish now we see that the market
disruption is actually happening
much faster and we need to take into
account many activities so we start from
the intelligent awareness basically
giving the eyes to the vessel we are
also working on connectivity solutions
so transforming that the data from ships
to shore and we're building remote
operation centers so basically the
infrastructure that you need in order to
operate a vessels from shore side and
monitor them and then we are developing
autonomous systems starting from
navigation systems but also then later
on moving into machinery systems so
basically covering the whole whole
vessel that will be made
autonomous one by one we're looking to
basically automate the data flow from
from sensor censoring to data
warehousing to annotation and then to
machine learning models and training the
models and we're looking to automate
that data flow and and really Google is
is the best partner for that
autonomous ships will affect basically
safety reliability and efficiency those
are the three main driver safety
reliability and efficiency that is
basically driving driving the whole
development on safety side you will have
a lot of accidents that are happening
today are are happening for the crew on
board the vessels and now we can save a
lot of accidents from happening when we
are actually moving the work to shore
side or or then making that work more
more automated in the future so that is
one thing and of course reliability
comes that there's a lot of breakdowns
today the the systems onboard the
vessels are not reliable so they have to
do a lot of maintenance while in
operation today in the future when when
the systems are more autonomous they
also need to be more reliable so they
there isn't so much need for the kind of
maintenance work that you have onboard
the vessels today and then on the
efficiency side you can of course now
have the same team of experts sitting in
a in a good office environment
supporting multiple ships or tens of
ships instead of having technical
expertise in in each of the ships so the
work is the same but now more more
efficient
we can already use a lot of solutions
that have been created for other
industries in the machine learning space
and we can now apply them to change the
shipping world as well there's a lot of
things we haven't done yet so we need to
for example create you know the machine
learning models and train them for for
marine use we need to basically gather
the data so that we can we can train the
models also for example in night time
and so it and different weather
conditions and different viewing angles
that kind of data set we need to create
so we can have the best models out there
in in in ships you have a wider area to
cover and we're using lidar using radar
HD cameras they have to cover so much
white area because there can be very
unpredictable of a lot of vessels that
requires a high computing power onboard
the vessel and the good thing is that
they have a bit more time to do the
analysis for example compared to cars
some of the Google cloud technologies
were using include for example
tensorflow processing unit that we can
have on onboard the vessels you have
data jobs you have hyper tune and and in
data labs those are the the tools that
have solutions that have immediate
benefit for for the autonomous ships key
takeaway is basically speed and
flexibility to bring this to the market
fast so don't try to do too many things
in-house partner use open platforms and
collaboration to drive this innovation
fast